♪♪
-[ Dramatically ]
Now this here --
this here is
the Dance Move Generator.
We're going to take turns --
-[ Dramatically ] This here.
-This here. This right here.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normally ] We're going to take
turns hitting this here button,
which will randomly select
a never-before-seen dance move.
Whoever's turn it is has to make
up a dance for that move,
and the best dancer wins.
And in honor of "Atomic Blonde,"
the songs we'll dance to
will all be '80s themed.
-Oh, okay, cool.
-And from the movie soundtrack.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Charlize, since you are the
guest, why don't you go first?
Let's start
the Dance Move Generator.
And when you're ready,
press this button right here
and it'll stop.
Trapped in a something...
That's spaghetti something...
-Oh, my --
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
-That was the movie --
That was the movie
I was in years ago.
Went straight to DVD.
-That's not a mistake?
-It's filthy. Filthy.
-That's actually
what you meant to write?
-Uh, yeah.
"Slap the Giraffe"
is the name of the dance.
[ Laughs ]
And you have to make it up,
and Roots,
start off with some good music
here from the --
-♪ Earth below us,
drifting falling ♪
-Oh, yeah.
-♪ Floating weightless ♪
♪ Falling, coming home, oh ♪
-Oh, hey, hey, hey!
Hey! Leave him alone.
Oh, my gosh.
Hey! Oh, hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How do you make that look cool?
-That giraffe.
-How do you make that look cool?
I can't believe you.
I know, you're so cool.
I was like, "Oh, that's sexy.
Looks like a good dance."
[ Laughter ]
All right, now --
-You actually --
-Yeah, I was like --
-"I got scared."
-Did I get scared?
Sorry, I get nervous.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, sorry. Whew.
It's my turn.
Let's start
the Dance Move Generator.
Let's see what's happening.
Stuck in a Thing.
I don't want to get
[ Laughter ]
The Where's My Phone? Where's
My Phone? There's My Phone.
-Oh, this is good. This is good.
I like it. Yeah.
-Okay, this is a dance.
How can I --
The Where's My Phone,
Where's My Phone.
-So imagine you're in a club.
-All right, I'm at a club.
And it's Where's My Phone,
Where's My Phone?
-♪ And I ran,
I ran so far away ♪
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ And I ran ♪
♪ I couldn't get away ♪
♪ And I ran ♪
♪ I ran so far away ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm in a club!
I'll call you back, Mom!
I'll call you back.
I'm in a club again.
You know me,
I'm always at the club.
-That was so good.
-I had the phone in my hand
the whole time.
-The whole time?
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't here?
-No, it wasn't
here, here, here, here
or in my cargo shorts.
[ Laughter ]
Which I always wear to the club.
Got to use the upper pockets.
All right, here we go.
Let's start the generator.
This is for Charlize.
-Oh, boy another?
Oh, me?
-Yes.
-Oh, this is terrible.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, it's terrible.
-The Tennis Pro. The Tennis Pro.
-This is bad.
-I'm not a tennis pro.
-Help me out, guys.
-Do you play tennis at all?
-No.
-Okay. This is perfect then.
This is -- you're at the club,
and --
[ Laughter ]
This is the Tennis Pro.
Here we go.
-Got it. Got it.
-♪ Don't turn around, oh, oh ♪
-Cha-cha.
-♪ Der Kommissar's in town,
oh, oh ♪
♪ Don't turn around, oh, oh ♪
♪ Der Kommissar's in town,
oh, oh ♪
♪ Don't turn around, oh, oh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How do you do that?
How do you do that in heels?
-[ Laughs ]
-How do you do that in heels?
Just dribbling a ball, like --
how do you do that?
If I went to a club
and dribbled a tennis ball.
-So out of breath.
-What's happening? So good.
You pull it off.
I look like an idiot.
All right.
Clearly
you're the better dancer.
Why even compete
against each other,
when we can do one more dance
together?
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, here we go.
Dance Generator,
a dance we can do together.
[ French accent ] A finale!
[ Normally ] Oh, sorry.
-One, two, three.
Double what? Kayak?
[ Laughter ]
How do you do that?
-I call back.
No, I'm just kidding.
[ Laughter ]
All right. All right.
Double Kayak.
All right, you get the back.
You get the back.
All right, ready?
Double Kayak.
We can do this.
Wait, just give us a beat.
♪♪
[ Indistinct ]
-Yeah, okay.
-One...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
[ Indistinct ]
Charlize Theron right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How great is that?
That's all the time we have on
"The Tonight Show Dance Battle."
My thanks to Charlize Theron.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Michael Phelps!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪